VHAWWWWONDRL: I'll try not to be too annoying.
David: No, no, I appreciate you being on here, and just to confirm, I have your permission to record.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yes.
David: Perfect. So yeah, I just started the recording fantastic. And now we're just gonna jump into this process.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay, so let me real quick here.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I'm going to go look for a file right here that I might be able to use.
VHAWWWWONDRL: okay, so I do have an image. Okay. So what I would do is, I'm you know, I'm going to go up here. I'm going to go to add content. And I'm going to do an event.
VHAWWWWONDRL: and I've got an image. I don't know if it's going to even fit or not. But I'm going to do an event and here we go. So I'm going to do.
David: Yeah, and you, okay, fantastic.
VHAWWWWONDRL: What?
David: You. You don't have to go like with the date and the time, and and those things.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Well, that's because I have an event to post.
David: Oh, you haven't! Oh, perfect!
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yes. So that's why I was thinking, I'll just do something right now. And so let's see, start time. It's gonna be 3 30 pm. And the end time is gonna be 3, 34, 30,
VHAWWWWONDRL: 5,
VHAWWWWONDRL: 30 pm. And the time zone is going to be pacific.
VHAWWWWONDRL: What? Here we go. Oh, Los Angeles, okay. So I gotta make sure I get it in the right Va.
David: Got it. Got it.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay. So
VHAWWWWONDRL: then my event image, let me just go here.
VHAWWWWONDRL: And so I'm just. I don't know if this is going to fit or not fit, but it is ready to go.
VHAWWWWONDRL: So I have my image. And so it's just going to be a flyer for Town hall event.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay. And I gotta select
VHAWWWWONDRL: this right here.
David: Yeah. And as you're kind of going through this, what are you? What are you thinking like while you're going through these sections?
David: Well.
David: is it? Is it quick, easy? Could it be easier.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I. You know I don't really have anything. I mean it. It is. It's functional. So I don't have anything that I can really think of. I think the only thing I would say is like right here. I wish I could do a search
VHAWWWWONDRL: instead of having to scroll. If I could just type in Walla Walla or something, it would jump right down to me. That's 1 thing. It's like, I gotta scroll all the way through this list.
David: Yeah.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Get to my Va.
David: I know absolutely.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay. So now I here, I don't know what to do. I don't know. Does it? Tell me somewhere here what I'm supposed to be doing with this image. It doesn't tell me what size it needs to be.
VHAWWWWONDRL: And this this is one of my frustrations is when I go into any of these areas to upload an image. I don't really know what's the expectation of that specific area. So that goes back to my statement of the fact that if we're going to be doing events
VHAWWWWONDRL: you know, you want an image is the size. And then because if you want the whole image to show it needs to be this size, and whether it's an image with lots of text on it like this one, or if it's going to be something different. I would design my images in the other program to fit the specific purpose.
VHAWWWWONDRL: So like in the old system, we would have on the on the main page. When you did a story or an event, it would tell you that your little snapshot image needed to be, you know, whatever 125 by by 1, 15, or whatever it is, and then I would create that image and have it ready to go. And then, when I got to the actual event or the story.
VHAWWWWONDRL: it would say that image needs to be 250 by 250, you know pixels or whatever, and then I would get that image created so that I could upload them, and they dropped in, and they looked perfect here. I don't know what to do.
David: Yeah. No.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I have no idea. So usually I just leave it alone, and I just do save and insert.
David: So what's the difference between, save and insert and save and select? Why did you pick that one.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Save and insert means. It immediately jumps me back to this page, and I'm already here. If I do save and insert it uploads the image, and then it asks me, do I save and upload? Then it asks me, do I want to insert it? So I just skip a step.
David: Step. Is there any situation where you would not skip that step.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I. You know, I don't even know what that other one would be for, because it's just an extra step for me. Okay, so yeah.
David: Okay and fantastic. I don't need you to fill out the rest of it. I was really just concerned on that image uploading section, or if you went through it, Amanda would be very excited to see, but with our little amounts of time I'd love to do our next section.
David: so I'm gonna go ahead and share with you an
David: updated version that we're working on right now. This is just the prototype. So things aren't gonna exactly work as you'd expect like, but it's for the most part kind of showing that experience. So let me go ahead and share that right now in chat
David: year.
David: Oh, I gotta send it to you. Okay.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, chat. Okay, let me go to chat here. Okay, do I click on this.
David: Yeah, feel free, and then it should open up the prototype.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay.
David: Okay? And then on the left navigation there's proposed flow.
David: If you go like, all the way to the left sidebar
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, right here. Okay. Click on, proposed Flow. Yes. Okay.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Alright.
David: And I'd like you to kind of so let me just
David: pull this bit up.
David: So imagine that you've already started to create a new event for veterans.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay.
David: The date.
David: You've entered in the location for this. You could imagine you're instead of Walla Walla, it's Bronx. But basically.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Right.
David: And
David: What I'd like you to do now is now it's time to upload that image, so I'd like to for you to show me how you would go ahead and do that.
VHAWWWWONDRL: So is this working right here? Okay.
David: Everything should be clickable. But before oh, actually, if you could.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Sorry.
David: Oh, real quick! No, no, don't get.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Told me to go. No, you.
David: I'm jumping right into it, and I love that what I would like you to do as you kind of going through it just before you click on anything. Explain to me what you're thinking, and just kind of give me like a little bit of a narrative as you go. Okay.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Alright, so obviously in the the top part I'm putting in all the pertinent information, you know. Selecting the Va. I get to the event image, and I realize that there's 2 buttons there. One is to upload an image, the other one is to select image that you may have already uploaded because there's times you could have uploaded something that you're gonna reuse. And so you're just gonna go to your image library and select it from there.
VHAWWWWONDRL: That type of thing. So most of the time I have a specific image I'm going to be using. But you know, maybe I would have had a just a generic Town Hall
VHAWWWWONDRL: image that I use, and it's already been uploaded. So that's that's why I would do select from library.
VHAWWWWONDRL: and maybe there's other, and I haven't seen this by not clicking on it. Maybe there are sample images that I can use. I don't know but I know that when you upload images you have the opportunity to
VHAWWWWONDRL: And I'm trying to remember if and maybe because I
VHAWWWWONDRL: I I did that went ahead and inserted it if you can actually tell it, whether you want to use it only for you, or let other people use an image. You know I don't care if people use my image, because if it's something that is universal, go ahead. That just makes it me feel like they like my work.
David: Fantastic. Okay, so let's go ahead and go through that same process you've been doing.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay. So I'll just take the same image, and I'll just move it over here before.
David: So one thing about this prototype. It can't.
David: The prototype
David: can't take drag and drop, but it should take, drag and drop if that makes sense like the way figma works. I can't make it so that.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay. Now see, this is what I love right here recommended image size.
David: Oh, okay.
VHAWWWWONDRL: So it tells me what my size is. So, therefore, if I have something in particular that I want to everything to fit, that's exactly what I was looking for, so I probably need to do this correct.
David: Yes, and.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay.
David: This is just kind of like a simulation of how it might be.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay? So then I will just so this is showing me.
VHAWWWWONDRL: okay, drag frame to reposition image cropping. So
VHAWWWWONDRL: how do I drag it? It's not working.
David: Yeah, that's just the limitation of the prototype.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, okay. So let's say that I did it. Okay. So now I'm gonna go here. And then there's the file name. I do alternate text I select where it's gonna go.
David: You're gonna have to. If you click there, it kind of fills it up for you automatically.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, there we go. Okay. So I only have one selection right?
VHAWWWWONDRL: And then I save and upload.
David: What do you think?
VHAWWWWONDRL: What do I? What do I think about it?
David: Yeah, about those options. So just to save and upload.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I I think that's great. And again I'm I'm real excited. If it's going to give me a an opportunity to make my image match to the
VHAWWWWONDRL: per the the proportions that it needs to be.
David: Okay. So you went through that real fast, it seemed to me, which is great. So yeah, what? What
David: stood out to you about the new design compared to the
David: one that you're currently using.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Well, I mean it. It's a slight variation. Again it it seems similar. But like I said, if it's going to give me recommended image sizes. I'm going to record all that stuff down on a little piece of paper over here so that I'm able to go. Oh, I'm going to do an event, and you know that image needs to be the perspective. I think it said 7 by 2, or something.
VHAWWWWONDRL: but it also gave me the actual dimensions, so I would would love to be able to have that option.
David: You'd love that option. Yeah.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, yeah.
David: Tell me a little bit more about so there's a couple of things that
David: it! It was doing that. Maybe you noticed 1st of all, when you put the image in it automatically cropped the image.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yes, right?
David: Compared that to kind of selecting the different options of the one to one, the 7 to by 2, the free form, the square.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah, but I always got confused in the old. In the current version. I'm confused by that, because I don't know which one I'm supposed to select, because there's times I've gone through, and I upload something, and my image is like, Oh, God! That's not even what I wanted to show. So I have to back out. And you know, redo the image
VHAWWWWONDRL: and and move it so that you know I I have what's pertinent. That shows so
VHAWWWWONDRL: so there it automatically shows you the cropping. So you know, right away, if you need to make any adjustments.
VHAWWWWONDRL: and whether you can just adjust it by moving it up and down like it, you know, said I was supposed to be able to do, or if I needed to back out and do something to the image off to the side.
David: Okay? So you're a fan of that, that automatic popping.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yes, because then, you know, you know what it's gonna look like, because in the current flow you don't know what it looks like.
David: Yeah, okay. Another thing I wanted to bring up was, and I'm not sure if you noticed this
David: description. So the current version you have to fill out a description in this version.
David: Description is no longer there.
VHAWWWWONDRL: When you say description. What's the description describing the image.
David: Describing the image not help, but description. And I'm wondering how you feel about that adjustment.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Well, I I don't know what the description was used for, unless it is was meant that if you were sharing your image with other people that they would have more information about it. But I don't know. You can look at an image. Go. Oh, okay, there's a cool image, and you can tell by looking at the picture what it is. You may not even need the description. I don't know what it was used for before, you know. I just know that if you have to have alt text, you got to, you know. Put what you think is going to be appropriate for alt text.
David: okay.
David: fantastic.
David: Last thing, I'd like to kind of
David: talk about is just if you if you go ahead and click X again. Right next to that photo that you uploaded
David: in the app.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, right? Here. Okay.
David: Yeah, we're kind of like undoing it.
David: So
David: one other like major change in this version is really splitting up, uploading the image and selecting the image from the media library.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay.
David: And I'm curious what you think about
David: that update.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Well,
VHAWWWWONDRL: I I'm trying to figure out how it is different from the current one, because, like you saw me, I just skip to upload and insert, which I think is the same as uploading the image. And then you have select from media library. So before, when I 1st started using drupal. I go okay, select and up, you know, select, and whatever that was there and then I go. Oh, now I have to insert it. I was ready to insert it in the 1st place.
VHAWWWWONDRL: So here you get to choose whether or not you're just going to automatically upload the image, and, you know, be able to adjust it.
VHAWWWWONDRL: But like I said again, if if you already had an image that you'd already uploaded, and you know, let's say you did a story. Now you're doing an event, and you you want to go and use that same image.
VHAWWWWONDRL: and you know what's going to be in your library already. So that's how I'm looking at it.
David: Okay, for like, yeah, if it's already an event you want to bring to the story. Got it? Got it? Yeah. And if you do want to remember kind of what it currently is. If you go to the left navigation where you swapped from current to proposed.
David: you'll be able to see that as well.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah, I was just yeah. Okay, so current flow.
VHAWWWWONDRL: So when you add media.
VHAWWWWONDRL: okay, file name.
VHAWWWWONDRL: okay? So so here it's already. It's showing you this is the current one. So there are images that are already there.
VHAWWWWONDRL: And then. You can select one of those images, or you can select a file.
VHAWWWWONDRL: and let's say we're going to select this one.
VHAWWWWONDRL: And see here.
David: Oh, yeah, it'll have you. Yeah, right?
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay. So there we go and then do this right here and the alt text. So see here, I really have no idea what size. It needs to be.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I really don't. So I have all these different ways to crop it. But is it going to do me any good right.
David: Right? Because.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I don't know what it's going to look like in the end. That's why. I'm thinking, with the the proposed flow. You are going to see exactly what it looks like.
VHAWWWWONDRL: When you upload the image. And you know, like I said before, with this proposed one. And you you do an upload. It's telling you right now, recommended image size 1750 by 500. Man. I love that.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Now I can be ready. Yeah.
David: Yeah. And then how do you feel about where that image is? So once you upload the image, it just
David: at the top.
David: and you, you kind of have it. So yeah, if you can, you can go through it just to kind of.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah, and that's I think that's great. And then, you know, you have all your stuff there, and you save and upload.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Did it work?
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, oh, okay.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I've got to finish all that now. I can save and upload and
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, okay, so there! That time it didn't give me the option to adjust it.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Why did that happen.
David: Oh, that might have just been the prototype, but it it should. It.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay.
David: Have, the.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah, right? No, I I'm i i like how this looks. I.
David: Oh! Fantastic!
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah.
David: Good. That's so good to hear.
David: Just to be more mind. Mindful of your time. Just a couple last questions wrapping up.
David: So yeah, I would say.
David: to start.
David: what
David: of the 2 versions you've seen?
David: What? Which one are you more inclined to use or say that like makes your workflow a little bit more efficient.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Well again. I've already said it more than once. I think I like this new workflow just because I have an opportunity to be able to see what the image looked like before I
VHAWWWWONDRL: finalize my
VHAWWWWONDRL: my event, my project, you know, whatever it is that I'm doing, and like I said, I love the fact that it's giving me the proposed dimensions, so that if I need to back out and do something I can do that.
David: Okay.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I'm super happy with that.
David: You're super happy with that.
VHAWWWWONDRL: And and I wonder if you're going to hear that from other people? I don't know. I just am curious, because we've talked about it on our drupal, open our office hours, and I just said, Why can't you tell us the size of the picture, you know, and I don't know what it is, but that's what I've done for so many years. I want to know, so I can prepare my image.
David: Yeah. Have you heard from? You've have you heard this kind of similar
David: feeling from other folks?
VHAWWWWONDRL: I I think I have you know I've mentioned it in the past, and you know they just
VHAWWWWONDRL: I mean they couldn't do anything, because you know the current drupal is the way that it is. But I I would be interested. Not that you need to report back to me. But I wonder if you will hear a little bit more of this if people notice that it gives you proposed dimensions and pixels.
David: So that proposed them in the pixel, that is.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah, I love that. And then the fact that you can actually see it cropped before you before you click and finalize it. So that if, like, you said, if you need to adjust it because you want certain things and see, I noticed, just like on Facebook, if you're uploading things on Facebook for an image or something like that. And and you have that that banner that you know for the event thing, that banner sometimes, if your picture is a little bit too big. You want to move it so you can. So it it shows the pertinent information
VHAWWWWONDRL: forth. But yeah, because once they open up an event, they can click on it and see the full image. So again you have an opportunity to adjust it so it can say, you know town hall, or you know whatever. And then people will know exactly what it is. But yeah, I think it's great.
David: Oh, that's so great to hear. So yeah, it's 6, or for me, it's 6 o'clock. It's I'm I'm not sure exactly.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Wow! 6 o'clock.
David: We're on the 3.rd We're on the hour. Is this the do? Do you still have time, or do you?
David: I want to just be my.
VHAWWWWONDRL: A couple of extra minutes. I've just got to get to the store and back by 4 o'clock.
David: To apply.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Some shoes for a veteran.
David: Got it. Got it. Okay? Yeah, no, that's very important. I don't want to take too much more of your time.
David: I I think that what I'll do is I'll open this up to my observers if they have any questions. And after that I think we can wrap up.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay.
Amanda: I love. Yeah, I would love to know if there's anything you want to share with us about anything using drupal at all, that we we didn't talk about today that you want to share with us.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Well.
VHAWWWWONDRL: drupal is very templated, and I think that's great in some cases. But in other cases it can be very restricting. But I understand
VHAWWWWONDRL: why we need to have something to look similar across the way, and to have things.
VHAWWWWONDRL: you know, be consistent. And that type of stuff. One of the other things relating to images. They're
VHAWWWWONDRL: Sometimes it's really hard to add images. I'm trying to think of an example. But like I said, because these these templates are so
VHAWWWWONDRL: restrictive. I say it that way that sometimes I just have to find workarounds. You know that type of stuff, and you know, I'm a computer nerd. So I play around and stuff like that. But I I do appreciate the fact that you know, I just open up templated pages, and then I'm able to drop stuff in there. And so that's pretty cool. And there's a pretty darn good selection of of different types of templates for me to be able to accomplish what I'm doing.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I know it's not like real web design. But again, I I think it's important that all of our Va pages look alike, and you go to the same location on every Va website, and you'll be able to find this information and not in the older system. People would put things in different places, and you would go to their web page and go, okay, where is this? But on our
VHAWWWWONDRL: sites, you know it's it is
VHAWWWWONDRL: every Va. If you're looking for a specific topic or something, this is where it's going to be. And so I like that.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Sometimes I like a little bit more free flow. But
VHAWWWWONDRL: I I know that I've had issues with images in the past.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I'm just trying to think what else. But
VHAWWWWONDRL: but in the end, you know.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I guess one of the other things is that
VHAWWWWONDRL: the
VHAWWWWONDRL: the different types of pages. You've got your service, page. You've got your what is it? I'm trying to remember what it's called here. I need to get over here to my drupal page so that I can see. Oh, where'd I put drupal? Where was it?
VHAWWWWONDRL: Which one was I working in?
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, maybe I closed it. I don't know
VHAWWWWONDRL: Let me let me just open it back up again. I guess I've got my little saved link here. Nope, gosh! Darn it.
VHAWWWWONDRL: I'm clicking around too fast.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, I'm having that same problem again, getting logged in.
VHAWWWWONDRL: How no fun is that
VHAWWWWONDRL: I must have closed my page. Okay, I've been having some login issues, and I've been working with the drupal help desk. But you know, when you have
VHAWWWWONDRL: you have a facility page, and then you have a there's like several different pages. And sometimes when I'm going and trying to edit a page, I don't know exactly which one to select, and I have to look at the types of pages it is. And is it a service level or facility level as opposed to? I don't know what the other one is. And sometimes I'm bouncing around because I'm trying to find a specific
VHAWWWWONDRL: page and stuff like that. Does that make sense.
Amanda: Yeah, I think I know what you're getting at like. I don't know if it says it. I don't know if it reads this way to you. But we call them like nodes. So sometimes, okay, I think that's what you're talking about, like.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Right.
Amanda: Hard to find which
Amanda: section or node that you need to edit rather than just picking like I want to edit content on this particular page you actually have to hunt down.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Yeah, and I actually have to open up the website. And I have to look and see where it is. Because I I will look at the URL, and it'll tell me exactly where to go. Look for it, you know. Stuff like that. I like the search feature when I'm looking for something in particular, like profiles. I can type profiles and boom. I can bring up all my profiles if I need to update a profile page, you know, for an employee or something like that. But what I was talking about is, you know, you create
VHAWWWWONDRL: create a page. And and maybe this, you know, like for radiology. I gotta. I gotta have a radiology and I gotta select a certain level. And then I gotta go to the system and facility. That's what is. You have a system page, and you have a a
VHAWWWWONDRL: facility page, and I have to remember one is big and one is small because I gotta do the big 1 first, st and you know, bring radiology in to my my list of services, and then I go in, and then I then I select the page to add it, and you know you have to kind of understand that flow, and I've helped a few people trying to like. I don't know what to do. I don't know how to get this service on my page.
VHAWWWWONDRL: and I'm able to say, Okay, break it down. This is how you do it. You've got to get your system page in there, 1st on your major list, and then you go in and you go in and you select the service and that type of thing, and and it's it is what it is. You just have to learn the quirks and the nuances, and then you can bounce around and do just about anything
VHAWWWWONDRL: that make sense.
Amanda: Yes, thank you so much, and I know you have to go. So I want to respect your time. But I really appreciate the extra.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Sure any any other questions like from
VHAWWWWONDRL: from was it Tim
VHAWWWWONDRL: or David? No, I was talking to David, or did Tim drop off.
Megan Commons: Tim. Tim had to drop off. Yeah.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Oh, okay.
Megan Commons: But, Linda, this is great. You're you're quick, you're fast, you know. You know exactly what you're looking for as you're going through stuff. So it was cool to watch you work.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Well, if you need any more testing, just reach out to me because I'll test something else. And I, you know, I mean, if we need to do more on this, and you have more questions. I'm happy to do that.
David: Yeah, I appreciate that. Yeah. And if you know anyone else that you're working with that is also interested that you're like, oh, they'd be a great person to hear our opinion, feel free to like, let us know, and we can share with them the link.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Okay, yeah, I will do that. In fact, my coworker down in White City in Oregon. She is a different style of of a website editor, she might be someone good for you to have her look at your setup and and give you her version of what she thinks.
VHAWWWWONDRL: So
VHAWWWWONDRL: you know I can. I can send. I can send her to you if you want. If she's interested in doing that.
David: Yeah, that would be fantastic. Okay, I appreciate that.
David: Yeah. And again, yeah, thank you so much for your time. You're really helping make va gov better and easier for everybody. So have a great rest of your day.
VHAWWWWONDRL: All right. Thank you so much. Everybody. I had fun doing it.
Amanda: Thank you. So.
VHAWWWWONDRL: Alrighty! Bye-bye.